Speaker 1: I don't know what's going on, guys,
with Fox News, but Sean Hannity will not stop
talking about Trump's dementia test. They just
will not stop talking about it and celebrating
it like some kind of major achievement. Here is a
new clip from yesterday. This was from yesterday's
Sean Hannity program. And again, Hannity talking
about Trump's dementia screening test that is
there nothing else to talk about for this guy
Speaker 3: and talk about the cognitive
side of things? Donald Trump took
that cognitive test. You told me
that he passed it with a perfect score, 30 of 30.
Speaker 1: You tosser doctors have never seen such
a perfect score. It's unbelievable. Sir, sir,
sir. Yeah. Just Hannity really impressed on me.
Speaker 3: It's a hard exam. You told me that
Speaker 1: you want Joe Biden to take one.
Speaker 3: What has been the response? No, I
haven't heard a single thing, Sean, and you're
right, this is not a laughing matter anymore.
Speaker 1: Why does the Biden administration have
to respond to Trump's former doctor, the same guy
who said Trump is six, three and ways to 39? By
the way, why does the Biden administration have to
respond to that? I simply don't get it. And this
is just everybody is obsessed with this now.
And of course, the idea is it's a distraction
narrative to try to get the attention on
something other than the complete absurdity
of what the Republican Party has become. Here's
just a reminder. Here's Trump ranting about his
cognitive test at the US Mexico border last week.
Speaker 3: But he did a test. Did I asit I tasted
and I'd like to see Biden ASAP. He he said he'll
get the first to this. Thirty five questions and
the first two or three are pretty easy.
They're the animals. This is a lion. A giraffe,
when it gets to around 20, is going to have a
little hard time. I think he's going to have
a hard time with the first few, actually.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So as I told you yesterday,
there are not 35 questions. There's 30
points. It's like 19 to 23 questions,
depending on how you count them. And again, Trump
obsessed with the idea that this is a hard test.
This is just a way to screen relatively serious
cognitive decline or dementia. And then again,
with Hannity, I mean, what's pathetic is
it's become a way to suck up to Trump.
They suck up to Trump by saying you're not
demented essentially is what's happening.
Speaker 3: In trouble is we waste it. I think I
can say that. I think we get what? You didn't get
one question wrong, did it? 30 out of 30. Wow.
Speaker 1: And they didn't get the crowd
cheering guys. The crowd cheering for it.
Speaker 3: More difficult after you got five
fifteen, I would say. But I heard the first three
questions are is it a joke or an elephant? Right.
Well, you know, that's what the fact is as they
take the first two or three questions and they
put it and they put them in, it's
Speaker 1: a really tough I mean,
I looked at it, guys, it's tougher than
what you know, in high school, I did an
economics and that was that was an easy one.
The Trump dementia test was really, really
tough. So how long will this obsession go on? I
really have no idea. But it's very, very strange